Hallelujah.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Hey
everybody.
The title of this lecture is that all
may be one and we have dealt in the last
few lectures with the political aspects
and tonight I want to start with the
religious aspects.
On Tuesday we are going to deal with a
lecture called strange fire. Don't miss
that one. That will be exciting. The
Vatican 2 meetings.
Vatican 2. The Pope is being carried in
during that meeting. And at that meeting
it was decided that the churches, the
Protestant churches
may remain in their confessions and
obtain salvation
provided of course that they accept and
acknowledge the supremacy of the bishop
of Rome. Now after Vatican 2, it was
Kana the Jesuit. Strange how they keep
popping up. I know I'm saying this
frequently, but it's just a fact. He was
the one who was commissioned to take
this message to the world that everyone
could remain in their confession
provided they acknowledged the supremacy
of the bishop of Rome. And I've already
dealt with this, but I'm going to go
into a little bit more detail now.
uh Paul Neta
who was uh held a position at Zavia
University Cincinnati where he's
professor of theology. He studied under
Carl Rana and he wrote this book no
other names and in this book no other
name he writes certain interesting
things. He has a commentary on it. It's
interesting that they have uh this
little uh humanist man over there on the
book tells us it's humanism.
He write faces the conundrum of what the
committed Christian believer does
theologically in the face of growing
evidence scholarly and from personal
encounter that there are other ways
religious ways of leading a full
authentic human life than the Christian
way.
Are you beginning to see something?
Can a person be saved?
Definition
that is come to live a truly human life
by some other name than that of Jesus
Christ. Hello. Let me just recap there.
To be saved means to live a truly human
life. Is that correct? Theology.
This is a professor of theology and this
book is prescribed in virtually all
seminaries of theology in the entire
world.
Nitto's answer is one can be saved by
some other name.
And then he proceeds to show how this
affirmation can be squared theologically
with full Christian commitment.
This is first rate creative theology.
That's the only sentence I agree with.
It is creative theology, but it's
definitely not biblical theology.
Well, at the second ecumenical council,
if the Bible is not going to be the
norm, we'll have to replace it with
something else. And it was decided in
document 515 of page 515 of the
ecumenical doc documents that were
written at Vatican 2 documents. The
unity of all Christians may at last be
restored to shine forth. For all peoples
are called to be a single new people
confessing one Jesus savior and lord
professing one faith celebrating one
eucharistic mystery. There are lots of
problems with there in this particular
one particularly the eukaristic mystery.
All Christians should be of an
ecumenical mind. Document Vatican 2 page
515. The Catholic catechism will tell us
that Vatican 2 did not change the
doctrines. It only appeared to t change
the doctrines. This is the present
catechism of the Catholic Church.
Article 816. The sole church of Christ
which our savior after his resurrection
entrusted to Peter's pastoral care
commissioning him and other apostles to
extend his rule. This church church
constituted and organizes society in the
present world subsists in the Catholic
Church. The second Vatican council
decree on economism explains for it is
through Christ's Catholic Church alone
which is the universal help towards
salvation that the fullness of the means
of salvation can be obtained. There's
been no change in doctrine. Only
Protestant believe that there has been a
change of doctrine. Wounds of unity.
Article 817.
Where there are sins there are also
divisions, schisms and heresies. So if
there was a division then it was sin. So
who's the sinner?
The one who separated
towards unity. Christ bestowed unity on
his church from the beginning. And uh
this is something the church can never
lose. 820
it didn't change. It still governs the
rules the church through its supreme
pontiff and bishops. Everybody will have
to acknowledge this. This why priests J
O Connell says the final object of
ecommenism as Catholics conceive it is
unity in the faith, worship and the
acknowledgement of the supreme spiritual
authority of the bishop of Rome. That's
the bottom line.
The church bond of non-Christian
religions, all nations form but one
community. They want the same relations
with Muslims with all the other
religions. Let's make sure that this is
true. This was the catechism. It can't
be wrong. Further questions answered.
Bonafentia Hinwood Vatican 2 teaches in
several places that the Catholic Church
and it alone is the church founded by
Jesus Christ. No change in the Vatican 2
documentation. Then September 5, 2000,
uh the Vatican made this quite clear.
The churches examined the Vatican
statement. 36-page statement said other
Christian communicates such as Anglicans
and other Protestants are not churches
in the proper sense.
Canon David Oliver, minister of St.
Thomas Anglican Church says, "Oh well,
it's okay whatever other churches are
not sis no sisters of ours." The Vatican
insists and we remember that Carl Rana
said must always be clear that the one
holy catholic and apostolic universal
church is not the sister but the mother
of all the churches. So that's the
latest statement, definitive statement
from the highest sources in the Vatican.
Vatican 2 changed nothing. These are
some of the comments of the other
churches. Churches are stunned by Pope's
attack. Protestant churches expressed
disappointment etc. But nothing changed.
They were still in the ecumenical
movement. The Washington Post has said,
"A new Vatican dictim issued today
declares that individuals cana obtain
full salvation from earthly sin only
through the spiritual grace of the
Catholic Church." There you go. And that
other faiths including Protestant
Christian ones have defects that place
their followers in gravely deficient
situations. And that includes Muslims,
Hindus, Jews, everyone. They have to
accept Catholicism as leader. That's
what the Vatican teaches. Now, how are
you going to do this if the Bible so
clearly condemns Catholicism?
Well, Vatican and the Sunday again, the
documents Vatican 2, any endeavor must
be made to make Sunday a genuine day of
joy and worship. We must celebrate the
pal mystery. It must be the primordial
feast day. There must be freedom from
work. shall not have precedence over
Sunday. All feasts are important. Then
it says the supreme manifestation of
this is the Sunday assembly. So again,
Vatican 2 reiterated that Sunday was the
day that was to be kept. And they call
it the Lord's day. And in their
catechism, article 2174,
they admit that we all gather on the day
of the sun, for it is the first day
after the Jewish Sabbath. There's no
such thing as a Jewish Sabbath. The
Sabbath was instituted in Eden long
before there was a Jew.
Now, Sunday in Christ's Passover, Sunday
fulfills the spiritual truth of the
Jewish Sabbath and announces man eternal
rest from God. And it comes from
tradition. This all stands in their
catechism. I'm not going to go into the
detail. So now, if you're not going to
have the Bible as basis, then you better
give the people something else. Musical
celebration. This is page 83. Vatican
documents actively participate more
willingly. Uh format of the celebration
and degree of participation should be
varied as much as possible. The liturgy.
Now the liturgy is everything that
happens in a church beside the sermon.
It marvelously increases the church's
power to preach Christ. So now let's put
more emphasis on the liturgy and less
emphasis on the what? the preaching and
they even call it in some documents the
holy liturgy a sign lifted up amongst
the nations and to gather the children
that are scattered until there is one
fold one shepherd of course that has to
be the pope
how are we going to do this is Vatican 2
their documentation document Vat Vatican
2 quote in all popular devotions the
psalms will be especially useful and
also works of sacred music drawn from
both old and more recent heritage of
sacred music, popular religious songs,
organ, other instruments,
characteristics of a particular people.
The participation and celebration should
be internal but must also be external.
Internal particip
participation by gestures and bodily
attitudes, acclamations, responses and
singing. In other words, Vatican 2 says,
"Let's make the service lively. Let's
start moving. Let's have some bodily
attitudes. Let's shake the arms. You
know, then it's not so important whether
you have your Bible. In fact, it's hard
to hold the Bible if your arms are
swinging around like cartwheels.
How must the songs be? Let's go again to
the catechism. Article 1157. Song and
music fulfill their function as signs in
a manner all the more significant.
That's fine. There's nothing wrong with
singing. Singing must be beautiful and
to the glory of God. But they said that
music must be emotional.
Quote, "Vatican Catechism, how I wept,
deeply moved by your hymns. Songs and
voices that echoed through your church.
What emotion I experienced, sounds that
flowed in my ears, distilling the truth
in my heart, a feeling of devotion
surged within me, tears streaming down
my face. Tears that did me good." So the
more tears and the more emotion, the
better. switch the mind off and switch
on something else. And so the papacy
started using rock groups and the pope
started singing to abba music and all
this sort of stuff started coming into
the churches which was unknown before.
This is the pope's personal little rock
band that goes with him sometimes when
he travels. These days they've advanced
to the more metal groups and all of
those.
And by 1967
the uh faculty and students of the
Catholic Deesma University started
becoming charismatic.
By 1968 the world council of churches
uh had uh Catholics as observers. By
1975 there were observers in Nairobi. By
1975, a mass mass gathering took place
at Rome and Pope Paul II actually
started speaking in tongues.
Here it is. Christianity today, June 6,
1975. Bishops, archbishops, cardinals
struggling to keep their hats in place
sang and danced in ecstasy, embracing
one another, raising their arms to
heaven. And Pope Paul V 6th's address
was punctuated with ecstatics.
So he started speaking in tongues. Great
example for the church.
The Lutheran church. By 1974,
the US lat Lutheran Roman Catholic
dialogue published papal primacy and the
universal church. They were beginning to
play with the idea that Rome would again
be the head of the churches. The
Presbyterians, Congregationalists,
Methodists followed. Colin Buchanan
writes, "The emergence of the church of
Rome as a partner in ecumenical
discussions and the impact of the
charismatic movement totally changed the
ecumenical relationship." So this new
spirit makes the talk between the
various opposing factions more and more
possible. By 1975,
there was a common catechism where the
moral directives in the decalogue were
questioned, where many passengers in the
New Testament were put in the mouth of
Jesus, things that the historical Jesus
never uttered, the physical resurrection
is a problem full of difficulties,
etc., etc., starting to question the
Bible. By 1977, there was a joint Roman
Catholic Commission which issued
together with the Anglican Church this
statement. It seems appropriate that in
any future Union universal primacy such
as has been described shall be held by
the Roman Sea. So the Anglican Church
said okay pope shall be head. By 1989,
the Anglican Archbishop of Canterbury,
the Reverend Robert Runy, went to Rome
and urged Christians to consider the
primacy of the Pope better together.
There they are. And then came the famous
signing of the document where they
actually signed. There is the signing.
The Pope and Runy signed the declaration
at Canterbury and the Pope is now the
head of these churches. And some nice
Masonic signals. Yes, they're going to
be together. And the queen, well, she
and her entourage visit the pope and
say, "Well, what did um Prince Charles
say? I do not want to longer be the
protector of the faith, but just
protector of faith." So, Protestantism
goes, and of course, much marching in
the in the streets of the United
Kingdom. The next um
archbishop of Canterbury is Kerry. And
Kerry is remarkable because of his
charismatic renewal and speaking in
tongues. So the Anglican Church the
first to go Romewood bound. Now this is
the famous St. Paul's Cathedral. There
it is. The London bus. I photographed
this myself. And this is a stunning
picture.
What do you see? What does it look like?
It looks like a miniature of the
Vatican.
Yes. In fact, it is a replica of the
Vatican. And the very amazing thing is
that uh St. Paul's Cathedral never
looked like that. Never looked like
that. In fact, it used to look like
that.
But now it has been totally rebuilt and
it now looks like that.
Uh doesn't this sound remarkably like an
image of the beast?
an image of the beast. Well, let's go
inside. You have to be very sneaky with
your camera when you go in there.
And this is what it looks like now.
There's the main altar. Wow. The main
altar is an exact copy of Benini's
canopy in Rome. That means the
Protestant church here has copied Rome.
Very interesting. There are the black
and white squares. They have cupids with
other angelic beings, male, females,
etc. And if you look at the ceiling and
you photograph the top, you will find
beautiful all masonic symbols. This is
masonry. This is not Church of England.
So the church of England has capitulated
and has become part of masonry and
therefore we could say Luciferian.
Sad but true. Well, in front of the main
altar, you have the typical solar
symbols. Looking from the top, it's like
a witch's cove. It's been restructured.
This is our cultism. In fact, it even
has the black and white pentagram on the
floor. And on the floor, it has the
symbol of the serpent with a tail in the
mouth representing the sun and the moon.
By the way, those are my shoes. They
were nice and clean.
and the solar deities on the floor. So
this is nothing other than Catholicism.
Here are symbols of uh new age. These
are the peacock symbols of Lucifer, the
triangles in the in the circle, the
hexogs
and of course the corpses under the
altar and IHS on their and sun blazes on
their utilities. Also the mythical
pelican or bird feeding its young to its
flesh. These are occult symbols.
No wonder Pope John Paul too could write
in crossing the threshold of hope that
by the year 2000 we need to be more
united. For unity all churches must
accept papal authority. The pope said in
1995.
That's the condition of unity. Now, why
did the Reformation split from Rome?
Surely, the Reformation had good
reasons, biblical reasons. Revelation
13:8 said, "And all that dwell upon the
earth shall worship him whose names are
not written in the book of life of the
Lamb slain from the foundations of the
world."
Well, they have surely corrupted that
one in the modern translations, but
never mind. That's what it says. They
shall not be written in the book of life
if they worship this system by obeying
it. Here is the dawn tubin. This is the
Lutheran mother church if you like in
Germany. And there they have huge
pictures of Mary with candles burning in
front of it. There you have it. This is
back to Rome. And the vet published the
picture of Martin Luther shaking hands
with the pope. Well, in the 1980s the
pope went to mines Germany and he said
ecommenism is an urgent task and then
Christians forging towards a new era.
churches have a pack. And then the
famous sinned in Germany, the Lutheran
sinned,
these old bones of contention if you
like, and they decided
the pope will no longer be called
Antichrist. Well, that's the end of the
reformation as far as Lutheran is
concerned. Time magazine uh then picked
it up and said, "A half millennium rift.
Lutheran and Catholics reach agreement
on the issues that once split Western
Christianity in two." And by 1999,
November 1st, churches end 500year rift.
So the Lutherans acknowledged the pope
and this amazing statement. Germany
calls to ask forgive Luther. For what?
For what? Should he be forgiven? And the
Calvinistic Church, they said we need to
have more respect for the icons and the
things. We cannot just uh go together
like this. Lutheran leader says Pope
might be global spokesperson for all
Christians. Friday church news notes
July 6, 2001. Ishmael Nooco, general
secretary of the Lutheran World
Fellowship, said in March that Lutheran
can certainly look to the Pope as one of
the spiritual leaders in the world
today. He went on to say that the
ecumenical movement requires Christians
to look into the possibility that the
Pope should become the global
spokesperson for all Christians.
So the Anglicans capitulate, the
Lutherans capitulate, the Presbyterians
capitulate, the Methodists capitulate,
everybody capitulates. In Germany, you
have now churches such as this one,
which I find interesting. There's the
Catholic side, there's the Protestant
side, and they share the bell tower.
And by the year 2000, the Knights of
Columbus, which of course is Jesuit
controlled, started sending icons of our
lady of Guadalupe to all the churches in
the world. Nativity of the blessed
virgin. It's wonderful, says Gino
Masotti, Grand Knight of the Knights
Columbus Council 11606
at the Precious Blood Cathedral that he
hopes everybody bows down to the icon.
Then came the joint declaration of
Lutheran and Catholics where they
discussed the doctrine of justification,
a brilliantly written document which
totally undermines the Protestant
principle. Well, if the Bible goes, you
better get livelier so that the people
don't read the Bible so much.
Theologians want to become lively. Let's
go to church to have, you know, some
liturgy, some movement. I don't know,
you know, you swing your arms, maybe you
can switch the air conditioners off. I
don't know what the aim of it all is,
but churches forged together. Recent
years many leaders of national churches
have moved from a no comment to the view
that the charismatic movement is the
best hope of renewal. Professor
Hollenberger said exactly the same thing
said Catholics Protestants come together
because of the charismatic movement
which has worked miracles charismatic
wave of unity amongst essay churches.
Then the Dutch Reformed Church says the
time is more than ripe to look at what
we have in common and not what separates
us. and all these great people say
exactly the same thing. The moderators
of all these great churches.
By 1990s, the World Council of Churches
was not the same as it used to be.
Originally, the World Council of
Churches was there to talk about
Protestant unity.
But of course, it had an agenda to be
led towards Rome. Why is Rome not a
member of the ecumenical movement?
because it never separated. It's the
mother. It's the the the kitties that
might come together to go back to mommy.
That's what's got to happen. If Rome
became a member of the ecumenical
movement, she would say that she's one
of the sisters. She's not. She's the
mother. So, she cannot be. And at the
World Council of Churches, they said
here, "Come, Holy Spirit, renew the
whole creation was the overall theme."
Now the lady who was in charge of the
main speech in the beginning was Miss
Chung as she burns a list of the dead
she invoked. Well, she gave the address.
She is now professor at UTS
and she uh arrived on the stage dancing
with Aboriginal men in loin cloths and
etc. And then uh she invoked the dead.
She called up Hagar, Uriah, the male
babies killed by Herod, Jon of Arc,
people killed in the gas chambers,
Mahatma Gandhi, Steve Bo, Martin Luther
King, and finally she also called up the
spirit of our liberator, Jesus Christ.
Very nice. And then she burnt the list
as a symbol. Now, let's look at what
happens here. combining combining verbal
fireworks with a performance by Korean
and Aboriginal dancers. Chung rendered a
dramatic evocation of a female Holy
Spirit. She linked it to Hagar,
exploited and abandoned by Abraham and
Sarah. I also know that I no longer
believe in an omnipotent macho warrior
God who rescues all good guys and
punishes all bad guys. 18 times Chung
summoned the spirit of the dead who have
suffered injustices and claimed that
without hearing the cries of these
spirits we cannot hear the voice of the
Holy Spirit. Don't bother the spirit by
calling her all the time.
Add Chung I hope the presence of all our
ancestors spirits here with us shall not
make you uncomfortable.
Well, is this uh biblical? Yes or no?
Definitely not. But she is the minister
of the biggest Protestant church in
Korea and she is now also professor at
UTS.
Chung Hung was a graduate of the Union
Theological Seminary which I've already
told you is Masonic. Chung was professor
of Korea's Awa Women's University, the
world's largest university for women
with two 20,000 students. She said, "The
three goddesses I want to share with you
are Kali, Hindu, Quanin, Buddhist, and
Anna, Philippines, my new trinity."
Interesting. She added, "The Christian
Church has been very patriarchal. That's
why we are here together in order to
destroy this patriarchal idolatry of
Christianity."
Okay, so that's the main spokesman at
most of the World Council of Churches
meetings.
She explains, "I came from shamanist
Buddhist and Confucious and Tauist and
Christian tradition. When I look at our
history of religion, we have more than
5,000 years of shamanism,
more than 2,000 years of Tauism, almost
2,000 years of Buddhism, 700 years of
Confucianism, and only a 100 years of
Protestantism in Korea. Therefore,
whenever I go to the temples, I look to
Buddha. I feel so young. Buddha died is
in his in his 80s. Jesus died when he
was 33. Maybe Jesus should be called too
young to understand.
Well, I feel like my bow my bow is
shamanist. My heart is Buddhist. My
right brain is confusionist. My left
brain is Christian. Kung continued. I
call it a family of gods and they are
together. So do you see the direction in
which the world council of churches is
moving? Uh Jung also said, "We believe
that this life-giving energy came from
God and is everywhere. It is in the sun
in the Oh, here we go again. How
nauseating." What is this?
>> Pantheism.
It is from the ground and it isn't from
the trees. If you feel very tired and
you feel you don't have any energy to
give, what do you do? Sit in silence.
Maybe you go to a big tree and ask,
"Give me some of your life energy." or
you ask the sun to give you some life
energy. Well, is this Christianity? Yes
or no?
>> No. This is absolutely not Christianity.
Kung was also a speaker at the World
Council of Churches in Arari, Zimbabwe
in November 1998 where she performed the
central dance. Dr. Kung declared that to
witness about Jesus Christ to another
person is in reality an act of violence.
Now, let's get to the hub of the matter.
To witness about Jesus Christ is an act
of violence. Why?
Because you are doing what? You are
going against the human rights of the
other individual who might be a Buddhist
or a Hindu or this or a that. He has the
right to be what he is. And if you tell
him something else that you have to
believe in Jesus Christ, then you are
committing an act of violence. So in
other words, what I'm doing is an act of
violence. Okay?
when reminded that Jesus said in John
14:6 that he is the only way said Jesus
was mistaken.
Okay, that's why the World Council of
Churches uses demons and all kinds of
interesting things. And we have O.
Now, what does ocom mean? Here we have
an example of oi.
Well, let's ask the world council of
churches webpage. What o actually means?
The word ecommenical is derived from the
Greek term ocom which may be translated
as the whole inhabited world. It is in
seeing this world as gods that we see
oursel as one. It is in seeing all the
world's people as made in God's image
that we are called to protect the
welfare of everyone.
Interesting.
Now remember that I always show you that
Gary Carr said the ancient Babylonian
religion through cabalism etc through to
Freemasonry controls Marxism, the
American secret political sciences, the
International Banking and the World
Council of Churches. Do you think he
might have been right
with their teaching? Jesus was wrong. He
wasn't young. He was too young to
understand.
We have nature worship. All of these
things that is definitely not biblical.
What does Alice A Bailey the founders of
Lucifer Trust predict in 1919?
She predicted the appearance of a
universal church of which the definitive
outline will appear towards the end of
the century.
There will not be any dissociation
between the universal church, the sacred
lodge of all true masons. See how
they're bringing it together? and the
inner circle of the esoteric societies.
In this way, the goals and work of the
United Nations will be solidified and a
new church of God led by all the
religions and by all of the spiritual
groups shall put an end to the great
heresy of separateness.
Good. This requires a whole lecture.
This is heavy stuff. So, there's a
lecture coming, the UN and the occult
agenda. It's on your paper. This is very
heavy. She says the churches, the
lodges, sacred lodge by the way, and the
esoteric societies by the end of the
century will work together to bring
about this new world religion.
Now, as a Christian believing that Jesus
is the only way, can I join the society?
Yes or no?
>> You're all so adamant. This is very
strange.
Norman Vincent Peele. Now, who is Norman
Vincent Peele? probably one of the
greatest preachers of our of our times.
33 degree Freemason.
Freemasonry has always welcomed men of
all faiths and religious beliefs to
enter its doors. The only requirement is
for good men to believe in the supreme
architect and the immortality of the
soul. None of which is of course
biblical. Masons in fact go beyond the
narrow sectarianism of limiting dogma.
They agree with the statement of the
famous statesman and writer Edmund
Burke. The body of all true religion
consists to be sure in obedience to the
will of the sovereign of the world in a
confidence in his declarations and in
imitation of his perfection. That's what
Norman Vincent Peele said who was a 33
degree Freemason as is Bishop Carl
Saunders 33°ree Freemason United
Methodist Church. Rabbi Seymour Atlas
Dr. James Westbury executive director
and editor of the Sunday Georgia Baptist
Journal is a 32deree Freemason. Reverend
Louis Grant, District Superintendent,
United Methodist Church, 33 degree
Freemason, Reverend blah blah blah blah
on and on and on and on. Well, Norman
Vincent Peele said, "I have found the
Scottish right and the symbolic lodge
espouse the belief of no one religion,
but are a respectctor of all major
religions of the world." And Billy
Graham says that Norman Vincent's Peele
is his great mentor. Interesting. He has
a 33 degree mentor.
Billy Graham, the world's most popular
Christian evangelist, is was listed on
web pages as a 33 degree Freemason by
themselves. After much criticism, they
took them off all the lists. Shaw, who
was himself a 33 degree Freemason,
revealed that Billy Graham was at his
initiation ceremony. But in his book,
The Deception, he talks about a
prominent evangelist who attended it so
that he could get his book published.
Norman Vincent Peele is a definite 33
degree Freemason, ex-grand Chaplain of
the Grand Lodge of of New York. This is
the one that Billy Graham said is his
mentor. Robert Schuler,
33 degree Freemason. These are webpage
sites where you can look it up. Uh but
of course there are many many writings
which confirm this. So this is not the
only source. I'm just quoting from the
sources. Oral Roberts, Jesse Jackson, uh
most of the early founding Mormons, we
know that. Jehovah's Witness, we know
all that. Peele, let's have a look at
Norman Vincent Peele endorsed the
chneled messages called the Jesus
letters written by Jane Pzera and Annie
Brown. So he endorsed chneled letters.
The amazing holy letters were written
one each day over two uh year period
that began on a morning in 1978. She
said the letters were dictated by a
non-living spirit who identified himself
through a pen as Jesus Christ. There's
the quote. Peele's response. He adds,
"It little matters if these writings
came from Jesus of Nazareth or Jesus of
Jane. They are all the same
consciousness, and that consciousness is
God. I am part of God and Jane and Anna
are part of that same God. Right? That's
what Norman Vincent Peele taught. This
is the mentor of Billy Graham.
Interesting.
Speaking of Occultist Kresken, all he's
doing, says Norman Vincent Peele, is
dramatizing what I've been preaching in
my writings for years.
Another book, The Dead Are Alive, They
Can Do and Communicate with Us, was also
promoted by Peele. He gushed, "A
masterpiece. I hope it will be read
widely."
Okay, this is the mentor of Billy
Graham. Just remember that the book's
author is Harold Sherman, a psychic and
spirit medium, who also wrote a
companion book, You Live After Death. Is
that serpent language or devil language
or God language? Which one is it?
God language.
Pope John Paul visits a Jewish synagogue
in by 1986 87 he tours uh the US meets
with Protestants and Orthodox. 1889
Russia opens the door to the charismatic
movement. And so they're all coming
together in one big happy family. The
Southern Cross, the Catholic newspaper
writes, "Israel's chief rabbi pays a
visit to the Pope." The patriarch of
course of the Orthodox Church and the
Pope also meet with much Masonic
signaling going on over there. Israel
invites the pope to visit the Holy Land
and the Pope honors Schindler's widow.
This is the Rabbi Robert Jacobs. Let's
hear what he has to say on this issue.
>> And in 1965,
Vatican 2 changed that.
Jacob says the second Vatican Council
marked an historic turnaround for
Catholic Jewish relations. And he says
John Paul II has done extraordinary
things to show respect for Judaism. He
was the first pope to visit a synagogue.
>> No pope in Roman history had ever done
has ever done what he has done. It gives
all Jews a feeling that for the first
time in Christian church history,
Judaism is appreciated as having its own
integrity and is not demeaned. I think
it's a tremendous privilege to meet this
extraordinary pope.
>> And then when the pope visited St.
Louis, this is what he had to say. will
rejoice and blossom.
They will blossom with abundant flowers
and rejoice with joyful song.
That's interesting.
Well, here is Alexi, the Russian
patriarch. He's also a committed ecom.
And there he is with Cardinal Cassidy.
And they have much more freedom. This is
a signal picture by the way. Ecom, the
pope and the patriarch together. And we
have a revival of eastern orthodoxy.
Occultism is revived. Asian religions
are revived. Islam, Buddhism, Hinduism,
Shintuism, Sakagaya and spiritism. In
the world there is a revival of religion
and religious fervor and conflict is on
the increase. Have you noticed that?
Yes. Now why? Because through chaos and
conflict you will bring them together.
Make the pain of separation greater than
the pain of union. Thesis antithesis
synthesis is the Hegelian philosophy.
Great expectations. The patriarch of
Constantinople says we will join the
churches. Then the opening of the
Islamic Cultural Center in Rome.
Catholic bishops residing. Pope John
Paul greets them. Islam and Catholicism.
We've dealt with it in a whole lecture.
Coming together. The problem is how to
bring Judaism, Islam, Christianity all
together. These are documents from the
Catholic Academy of Tria. Note what they
are using over here. What is the
symbolism they are using with all these
strange symbols on their documents? Same
over here. Pentagrams, all the religious
symbols in a circle, papal seminary.
What is this structure here with the
mystic towels all around it? What does
that mean? The emblem of the centenery
of the Catholic Church in Cameroon.
Well, these are kalants and mandalas
that they are using. These are symbols
of Eastern religions. symbolizing
unity of all the churches, Pope and the
Dalai Lama together. And uh it is
interesting that we need to study what
the Protestant world has to say on this
issue as well. And we will do that in a
following session.
We have been discussing how the churches
are uniting
and I would like to show you the great
Protestant preachers and what they are
actually preaching. Now Robert Schuler
is listed on many many web pages as a 33
degree Freemason. Well, the proof of the
pudding of course is always in the
eating.
He wrote here in the fourth dimension
forward, I discover the reality. I
discovered the reality of that dynamic
dimension in prayer that comes through
visualization.
Don't try to understand it. Just start
to enjoy it. It's true. It works. I
tried it. Now, visualization is the way
in which you start visualizing something
and it becomes part of your fantasy
world. They train little kids to do
this. It's an occult technique. It's
occultism.
Here is his famous cathedral, the
Crystal Palace. There he is. This great
preacher. By the way, he took the plans
of this cathedral and he took them to
Rome in order to have them blessed by
the pope. That's very interesting that
Robert Schuler should take these to the
pope to have them blessed. His son is
now obviously taking over the ministry
as he gets a little bit older. Robert
Schuler quote from self-esteem the new
reformation. He writes, "Classical
theology has ered in its insistent that
theology be God centered and not man-
centered."
That's very interesting.
That's spoken like a true Freemason.
Wouldn't you agree? Yes.
On page 153, he writes, "One classical
role of the pulpit in Protestantism
has been to preach sermons."
Oh, which imply indoctrination more than
education. Within this form of
communication, there's an inherent
intrinsic inclination to intimidate,
manipulate, and h offend the person's
most prized quality of humanness, his
dignity.
Well, that sounds like Vatican 2. Let's
move to liturgy.
Let's have all these wonderful things
other than the preaching of the word.
He writes on page 14, sin is any act or
thought that robs man myself or another
human being of his or her self-esteem.
That's interesting because I thought the
Bible said sin is transgression of the
law.
Isn't that right? He writes on page 26
27, "What we need is a theology of
salvation that begins and ends with the
recognition of every person's hunger for
glory."
Oh,
I thought that
justification
is something that actually lays man's
glory in the dust. That's what I
thought. It makes Jesus Christ more and
me less. Isn't that what the Bible
teaches? He must increase. I must
decrease.
Wow.
Page A68. To be born again means that we
must be changed from a negative to a
positive self-image.
From inferiority inferiority to
self-esteem, from fear to love, from
doubt to trust. Very interesting
theology. Page 75. The cross sanctified
the ego trip for the cross protected our
Lord's perfect self-esteem from turning
into sinful pride. Now that is just
plain blasphemy as far as I'm concerned.
Page 135. Christ is the ideal one for he
was self-esteem incarnate. I thought he
came to show humility, didn't he?
My Bible says he was humble.
Jesus never called a person a sinner.
Rather, he reserved his rightful rebuke
for those who used their religious
authority to generate guilt and caused
people to lose their ability to taste
and enjoy their right to dignity.
Interesting. I thought he said, "I have
not called the righteous but sinners to
repentance." Didn't he say that? So,
this man is obviously losing some
strange document. I don't know which
Bible he uses. He says, "The church's
problem is that it has a God- centered
theology for centuries when it needs a
man centered one. We're not bad, merely
badly informed about how good we are."
Oh, Robert Schuler,
that's an fascinating statement. It
would be an insult to the integrity of
any human being to call him a sinner.
I thought when he comes the Holy Spirit,
he will convict us of
sin and righteousness and judgment.
Jesus knew his worth. His success fed
his self-esteem. He suffered the cross
just to sanctify his self-esteem. And he
bore the cross to sanctify your
self-esteem. The cross will sanctify the
ego trip. Isn't it pathetic?
This man is not a Christian. He's a
Mason.
Now remember when I say Mason, I mean
high mason because the poor low lower
grades of Masons know nothing about all
of this. High mason. Let me qualify it.
Schula further amplified this latter
thought on the Phil Donov show. Schula
said, "Jesus had an ego. He said I if I
be lifted up will draw all men unto me."
Wow, what an ego trip he was on.
That's disgusting.
Questioner.
This is a questioner to Schula. How
could the cross, as you write, sanctify
the ego trip and make us proud in the
light of passages that say, "I hate
pride and arrogance." Proverbs 8:13,
"Pride goes before destruction."
Proverbs 16:18, "The Lord detests all
the proud." Proverbs 16:5, "Do not be
proud." Romans 12:16, "Love does not
boast. It is not proud." 1 Corinthians
13:4. In fact, Paul warns Timothy that
in the last days, men will be lovers of
themselves. 2 Timothy 3:2. Good
question. I like the questioner already.
Why should we do anything to encourage
people to become lovers of themselves if
Paul in fact warned others that would be
the state of godlessness in the last
days?
Schula, I hope you don't preach this
because you could do a lot of damage to
a lot of beautiful people
if you preach that text. Oh man, I sure
hope you give it the kind of
interpretation that I do. Or I'll tell
you, you'll drive them further away and
they'll be mad than hell at you and
they'll turn the Bible off and they'll
switch you off and they'll turn on the
rock music and Madonna. Just because
it's in the Bible doesn't mean you
should preach it.
It is be it is so difficult to preach
some of those texts and not come across
as lacking humility.
See how these people turn it around?
Robert Schula, what sets me apart from
fundamentalists
is that they are trying to convert
everybody to believe how they believe.
We know the things the major faiths can
agree on. We try to focus focus on those
without offending those who with
different viewpoints.
There's the quote USA Today Schula said,
"When we know we have been redeemed and
we know we are part of God's family, we
are ready to dream that great divine
dream of building the kingdom of God in
the world."
H thank
sword and trumpet. Now the kingdom of
God I thought was not of this world.
Didn't you think so as well? Robert
Schuler said after his thousands
telecast when he was congratulated by
Mother Terza, she was still alive there.
Billy Graham congratulated him. Serena
Scott King, Martin Luther, all the
living presidents of the United States
as well as Sammy Davis Jr. was a
Satanist. They all congratulated him.
What we need is a positive to positivize
the words that have only a negative
connotation. There's no greater damage
that can be done than to refer to the
lost sinful condition of man.
Let me tell you something. If man
doesn't realize that he is in a lost
sinful condition, then he will never
need a savior and then he will be lost.
We don't think anything has been done in
the name of Christ that and under the
banner of Christianity that has proved
more destructive to human personality
and hence counterproductive to the
evangelism enterprise than the often
crude uncchristian strategy of
attempting to make people aware of their
lost and sinful condition. Well, that's
disgusting.
Well, he goes further than that. Let's
have a look at what he really consists
of. The most effective mantras employ
the M sound.
You can get the feel of it by repeating
the words I am, I am many times over.
Transcendental meditation or TM is not a
religion, nor is it necessarily
anti-Christian.
Wow. You can chant I am. I am. I am.
What do you think about that? Now you're
saying I'm God. Surely you don't mean
that, Mr. Schuler, do you? Methodists,
Anglicans, all of them come together.
They all begin to leave believe in life
after death. Well, here in self-esteem,
the new reformation,
Robert Schuler writes, to be born again
means that we must be changed from a
negative to a positive self-image,
from inferiority to self-esteem, from
fear to love, from doubt to trust. And
we can pray. Note what Mr. Schuler says,
Dr. Schuler, sorry. Our Father in
heaven, honorable is our name. emphasis
in the original. What is Robert Schuler
saying? He's saying he's God.
Is this
biblical or is it demonic theology? You
tell me. You choose. It's demonic. Who
approves of his theology? Who likes his
theology?
There it says, "Discover your
possibilities. Robert Schuler, positive
inspirational guidelines. Who endorses
it?" Do Dr. Schulers has an amazing
ministry. Dr. Billy Graham.
Birds of a feather flock together.
Who is Billy Graham? Here he is. One of
the greatest preacher of our time,
Christian Winter. Here he is with Nixon.
When you went into this ministry,
politics lost one of its potentially
greatest practitioners. Remember that
Nixon had a Jesuit speech writer. Do you
remember that? We showed you those
quotes and uh you know if everybody
loves you in the world well gets kind of
scary. Here he is at Madison Square
Gardens. Here he is at the US Capital
during the presentation of the
Congressional Gold Medal that he
received with Al Gore sitting there on
receiving honorary doctrine from the
Roman Catholic Belmont College. Bill
Graham said, "The gospel that founded
this college is the same gospel which I
preach today." Hello, Billy Graham. I
thought you were a Protestant.
Why are you preaching Catholicism?
And please tell me
why in all your campaigns do you have a
team of 800 Catholic nuns and Jesuit
priests and all kinds of people like
that? And why after you campaign do you
channel them to the Catholic priests to
be incorporated in Catholicism? Why do
you do that if you are a Protestant?
The religious news service reported on
January 13, 1981, Pope John Paul was
closeted for almost two hours with the
Reverend Billy Graham, the world's best
known Protestant evangelist. Religious
news service. There it is. There he is
together with him. The Pope is almost an
evangelist. And here he is dressed in
black and the pope dressed in white
talking together.
It was through Billy Graham's
intervention that former President
Ronald Reagan set up an ambassador to
the Vatican against the Constitution of
the United States. He has been linking
agents from the White House to Rome.
Graham wrote, this is his own words,
speaking for himself, Reagan was the
first American president to appoint a
full-time ambassador to the Vatican.
Before he made the appointment, he asked
my view. I told him I thought it would
probably be a good thing in spite of a
number of potential problems concerning
the separation of church and state and
wrote an extended confidential letter
outlining my reasons. Among other
things, I told him I did not think it
necessarily violation of separation of
church and state. For whatever reason,
Mr. Reagan went ahead with a plan.
Later, my letter was leaked to the
press. I caused some constonnation among
my Baptist friends. Yes, of course, he
would cause a constonation, but his
Baptist friends might not know what he
is because it is so well covered up in
the world. If you want to read about
more about him, read Billy Graham and
his friends.
Robert Schuler's 1986 Possibilities
magazine had Templeton's photo on the
cover.
The lead article quoted Temple told that
nothing exists except God. That is
pantheism. And that the Christ spirit
dwells in every human being whether the
person knows it or not. That's
universalism.
Templeton. Now who received the
Templeton Prize?
Of course. Billy Graham. Graham told
Schuler during an interview, "Whether
they come from the Muslim world or the
Buddhist world or the Christian world,
they are members of the body of Christ
because they've been called by God."
Yes, you can be a member of the body of
Christ in any of those religions if you
unknowingly
do what the law requires because your
conscience dictates this. And God
overlooks the ignorance of those who do
not know. the ignorance God winks at.
But if you know the law and you do it
not, you will die. If you don't know the
law and you still break the law, you
will also die. That means eternally. So
evangelicals and Catholics join forces
eventually and Pope John Paul is
decrieded as the superstar of the world.
Pope deserves the title of first citizen
of the world. Newsweek said that in 79
already after September 11, ecommenism
received a tremendous boost.
All the religions started coming
together. The Muslims and the
Protestants and the Catholics, they were
all praying together.
Death of Protestantism foreseen. By
1997, the Episcopal Church with its
bishop here had the following to say.
Bishop Adler. is the word of the Lord
told us that what we are witnessing is
the end of an era that God is restoring
his temple and that there would be a
priesthood and episcoscopy
that was an apostolic concession a main
difference between the protestant faith
and Catholicism. Now this is this church
this is the basically the high church of
England in the United States.
Bishop Adler said that after the sermon,
he stood up to give a prophetic word but
fell on the floor and wept for 45
minutes.
Then he said, "We all sensed what God
was saying to us. We were witnessing the
end of Protestantism."
And then he said, "God's church is
Catholic." He declared, "It was Catholic
in the beginning and it will be Catholic
in the end." You see how the world is
coming together in unity. Churches agree
pope has overall authority. Isn't that
interesting? The pope wrote this and he
said in his crossing the threshold of
hope that by the year 2000 we will need
to be more united. 1999 June they wrote
the pope was recognized as the overall
authority in the Christian world in the
Christian world entirely by an Anglican
and Roman Catholic commission yesterday
which described him as a gift to be
received by all the churches.
Interesting. And then he has a gift of
authority. The 43page document, the gift
of authority, has been produced by the
18 member Anglic and Roman Catholic
International Commission. And it
concluded that the bishop of Rome had a
specific ministry concerning the
discernment of truth. What does that
mean? That is infallible.
So the Protestant world has given up
Protestantism.
Churches should hold seances.
Yes. Who said that? This was the
Anglican church in England. Now we're
ready for spiritism in the church. The
churches are really falling. Falling.
These are no longer prophetic words.
These are false prophetic words. These
are false prophets. They are preaching a
lie. And in the next lecture, it will
become abundantly clear what is
happening. Don't miss the next lecture.
Strange fire. we'll see some videos
which will be astounding.
So he said what what this Anglican
priest said is that we can actually talk
to the deceased and uh maybe we can
reach the atheists who died from the
other side and convince them now that
you see the living there after all you
don't have to be an atheist anymore. If
that theology was true couldn't God do
it?
the Roman Catholic controversy. James R.
White uh is a a writer who says that
today well are we coming together? There
are many reasons why we should say
separate. He sees the problems. The
Council of Trent said to check the
unbridled spirit. It decrees that no one
relying on his own judgment shall in
matters of faith and morals pertaining
to the edification of Christian
doctrines, distorting the holy
scriptures in accordance with his own
conceptions, presumed to interpret them
contrary to that sense which holy mother
church to whom it belongs to judge of
their true sense and interpretation has
held and holds. So only the church may
tell you what to believe. You goam,
you're too stupid to understand it
yourself. Interesting.
The papacy has it changed? No.
Refinement of evil where the pope
outlines that every single ancient
doctrine held by Rome will be held.
Therefore, can I be part of the
ecumenical movement? Yes or no? I cannot
be because I cannot accept this as my
spiritual leader. I have one leader and
his name happens to be Jesus Christ.
It's the only leader I have and I have
one creed and that creed happens to be
the Bible and the Bible alone. That's my
creed. Otherwise, I have no standard
whatsoever. Keeper of the straight and
narrow. There's Cardinal Ratzinger,
German-born Cardinal Ysef Ratzinger,
head of the congregation of doctrine and
faith. They make sure that every ancient
Catholic doctrine remains and that no
Protestant even recognizes it. They're
so sneaky. Here is uh Cardinal Kung and
uh these people Hanskung all they want
to do is bring about ecommenism. So they
make lots of Protestant noises. Didn't
the Jesuits say that if you want to win
someone make his noises? Yes or no? Yes.
Don't trust them one little bit. By 1986
we had the council of a sissi and all
the religions of the world were present
that included Islam, Hinduism all these
religions they all came together at
Aissi there's the pope there are the
patriarchs there's ransi there's the
Dalai Lama Hinduism Buddhism every
single thing was present where atissi
you know what's interesting
after the council of Aissi, there came
an earthquake and the whole cathedral
collapsed.
It's almost like God said,
guess what they did?
They instantly rebuilt it to its former
glory. Instantly. Immediately, it stands
as an icon to Aissi. And at this ASIC
meeting in ' 86, the first rot started
of accepting the papacy as the ultimate.
By 1999, this is what happened. The
United Nations of Faith moved mountains.
Article appeared in the Belgian national
newspaper as dated 30th August 2000.
A general rehearsal is taking place at
the highest level in the forum where the
supreme being grand architect, that's
Masonic language, or watchmaker of the
universe, if he exists at all, their
derogatory, is to recognize his own at a
time when the United Nations will
shortly host the summit of the
millennium
with the presence of the heads of state
of the entire world.
All the world's religious leaders have
been gathering in New York. How much of
the world's religious leaders?
>> All.
>> All. To discuss the most important theme
of world peace and tolerance. The more
distant objective to create a kind of
United Nations of Faith. Wow. There's a
whole lecture coming up on this. This is
fascinating stuff. where the
representatives of faith and
philosophies could meet in an order to
discuss the future together
while abandoning their fatwas, thesis
and other terrible arms of
excommunication and exclusion and
relegating them to the cloak room. Let's
get away from our separateness. Let's
come together. This is a very noble
econical initiative sponsored by whom?
Ted Turner, a 33 degree Freemason who
hates Christianity, who funded the
initiative. He is vice president of Time
Warner, founder of CNN, and for every
sin there is grace. 10 years ago, the
flamboyant boss of instantaneous
television had declared that
Christianity was nothing but an affair
for losers and freaks.
>> Okay, so he still believes it. Now, why
would Ted Turner finance something like
that?
because he says Jane Fonda his wife
turned Christian and that changed his
mind. I don't think so.
I think it's because he's a 33 degree
Freemason and they have an agenda.
Well, 2,000 representatives of very well
or less known religions, the one which
have participated the world over, which
are almost an affair of confidence only
known in the corridors of the UN or the
Spiffling Waldo Historia Hotel where
which will be used for the subsequent
meetings and work. The Pope sent the
African Cardinal Francis Arine,
president of the Pontipical Council for
Interfaith Dialogue. Representing the
Jewish faith was the Jewish rabbi lao of
Jerusalem. The Buddha were deprived of
the presence of the Dalai Lama. This
shows that the rel religion is never far
removed from politics. China threatened
to boycott the meeting if he went.
That's just a game they're playing.
Well, the initiative Bishop Desmond Tutu
said, "Let's go ahead with it." And in
the US and in particular in circles of
the UN, this first initiative has been
very welcome. Nevertheless, one needs to
render to Caesar
or rather to John Paul to his Jews. It
is indeed thanks to him that the way of
reconciliation was started at Aissi in
1985 culminating in that meeting in
1986.
Well, the pope then May 2001
visited the famous mosque in Damascus.
John Paul 2 made history by becoming the
first ever pontiff to enter a mosque and
urging Christians and Muslims to forgive
each other. That's the mosque. Remember
I showed it to you, the famous mosque in
uh Damascus.
And we walked through it
and uh had a look at this amazing
structure
with these
people having the same rituals as in
Roman Catholicism.
And you will remember that we spoke
about the head of John the Baptist that
is stored in this mosque. So it's
significant that the pope went to that
particular mosque to go and seek
reconciliation. Although reconciliation
is just a word for the goyam the outside
the inside has always been reconciled
and we know already that the pope then
kissed the Quran. So the initiative is
to bring all the religions. This is a a
symbol of the religions dancing
together. a symbol of Judaism and
Buddhism and Christianity and Hinduism
and all of them coming together in a one
great big happy family. Uh this is the
title page of Rotarian Bishop Leman's
document the world peace day and the
emblem of the world conference of
religions
Hinduism
Buddhism and finally we have a
parliament of world religions. Now this
parliament of world religions is an
outcome of the ASIS meeting and this was
their Africa day. They have the sun
symbol in the middle. There are
interesting symbols in this. So at the
center faith meeting in 1999 as a
reported associated press with a Dalai
Lama sitting by his right side. October
1999 there was another meeting uh in
Rome. The pope presided at a special
council of some 2,000 religious leaders
of various faiths, sects, and cults.
Now, I'm going to show you a video of
that in a moment of what happened there.
The pontiff told the assembled Buddhist
monks, Zorastian priests, Catholic
cardinals, Hindu gurus, American Indian
shaman, Jewish rabbis, and ecuomanical
clergy. That's all the Protestants that
there are that all must join in
condemning who
the Christian fundamentalists.
Wow, I thought the problems were
elsewhere. But he obviously has an
inside tact, so he knows who the real
problem people are. It's the Christian
fundamentalists. Why?
Because they commit the ultimate crime
of telling people about who?
>> Jesus. Don't you think there's a total
onslaught on Jesus Christ? I believe
there is.
Christian fundamentalist who abused
speech and whose efforts at converting
others incite hatred and violence.
Didn't uh Miss Kung say the same thing?
Yes or no? She said the same thing at
the World Council of Churches. So, we
want a unity, but please let this unity
be on a universal Christ. Just leave
Jesus out of this. This is an attack on
Jesus Christ. All present were in accord
on two key points. Number one, Pope John
Paul 2 was endorsed by consensus as the
planet's chief spiritual guide and
overseer.
That's interesting. And number two,
religious fundamentalists who refuse to
go along with the global ecumenical
movement.
That would include me, for example.
are to be silenced.
So, who knows how many times you can
still hear this message. They must be
denounced as dangerous extremists full
of hate.
That's why we have hate laws. You're not
supposed to preach this message. You're
not supposed to preach that Jesus Christ
is Lord. Then you are a dangerous
extremist full of hate. Well, I figured
I better preach it before we can no
longer preach it. And that's why I'm
here to tell you about these things. The
onslaught is not against me. The
onslaught is against the Lord. And he
predicted that this was going to happen.
Well, let's have a look at this Masonic
meeting. You will see three candles in
this meeting. That's Masonic. They light
the solar candles which are little
covered candles which are used in
Hinduism for example as solar candles
and in Buddhism and Eastern mysticism.
And you will see that they use all kinds
of music just like the Bible said. In
fact, the main rock band of Italy gave
the background music at the ceremony on
the one stage with the papacy on the
other stage and every religious leader
of note in the world was there of every
religion to bow down and give homage to
the pope. Interesting. Let's watch it.
My
know
my
challen.
for the on
you.
You won't get
there.
I don't need more.
It looks so smug, doesn't it? Well, here
they all are. Islam, Hinduism, Buddhism,
Shintoism, Sokagaya, all of them.
Protestantism, all of them bowing down,
acknowledging the Pope. Now, didn't the
Bible say that the whole world would
wander after him? Yes or no?
And that she would not suffer loss of
children. Didn't the Bible say that?
Judaism was there. All the religions
were there. Now this means that we are
very very close to the close of time.
There's an interesting picture that was
published once by the Spiegel there. And
here you have a statue of Caesar showing
a finger. That's actually a Masonic
thing, but never mind. There he does it.
And they have Mussolini on the other
side in giving the finger. And then they
have Rome here,
the pope, the church and the sin. And
they have the pope over there in full
sun worship regalia. And then they have
the prostitute.
It's almost like they know something,
right? This prostitute, the Bible says,
is the woman that rides the beast. the
great prostitute that is over the
nations and all the kings of the world
give their power unto the beast. We've
seen that the ruling powers in the world
actually come from very few families
today, highly occult families.
And the woman which thou sourcest is
that great city which reigns over the
kings of the earth. Revelation 17:8.
And I heard another voice from heaven,
saying, "Come out of her, my people,
that you be not partakers of her sins,
and that you receive not of her
plagues." Revelation 18:4.
What do you think they have planned for
those who harbor a spirit of
separateness?
What do you think they have planned for
those who say who say like the Bible
says come out and be separate that you
receive not her plagues and that you
don't take part in her sins? What do you
think will be their conclusion
about such a matter? I think this is a
very very serious issue and we're going
to have lectures on this when we get
there. We'll see what their final plans
are and who they actually pinpoint
as opposition.
That would be interesting, don't you
think? We'll let them speak for
themselves. In the meantime, as for me
in my house, I cannot join this
ecumenical council. And I would like to
uplift Jesus Christ to you tonight as
the only savior on this world and follow
the biblical way and none will be lost.
That is his promise. Why not take him at
his word? Amen.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Happy
home.
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
hey.
Oh my go
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh